I've been working on this movie for
three years Mindy Kaling on writing her
first feature film late night
independent films often take a more
circuitous path and that's my euphemism
for it is really hard to get it done
I've been working on this movie for
three years it's a comedy movie but to
make a comedy can submit heartbreaking I
need you okay
I need your pushiness and lack of
boundaries you love me no I didn't say
that I know I mean not in those words
but you know I didn't say it in any of
those words et spoke with the actress on
the red carpet at the Los Angeles
premiere for a long time bestie BJ Novak
came out to support being his typical
hilarious self I am thrilled that it's
finally at this moment I can't believe
it
what exactly is wrong with my bits
you're a little old a little wait what
can I do about that I mean I loved
working with Anna if I had to work with
her again that would be incredible have
you ever had a copper in your life I've
never had a Kathryn in my life no thank
heavens I haven't but I'm one of the
lucky ones because most comedy writers
are people who get into this field have
it because oftentimes big successful
personalities that are wonderful on
camera can oftentimes not be that way on
camera so what I've been like it
Mindy also dished on the upcoming reboot
of the iconic 90s flick Four Weddings
and a funeral it's terrifying and
exciting it's both because you know the
script is incredible Richard Curtis is
one of the producers which I think made
everyone feel really relieved and he
really believes in the project it was
this great and you know we're not trying
to do a remake we're not trying to
recast and find a new Hugh Grant or
Annie McDowell or and and we just love
our new cast it's a completely new world
but if you like the spirit of the movie
I think you'll really love this as many
areas and we know Andy does have a guest
role is there anybody else we can expect
and anyone else you can expect from the
original I think it might just be Andy
[Music]